dónde está el 32 en la recta numérica y
vamos a ver que del 0 a la primer línea
que tenemos hay una diferencia de 4 es
decir que cada una de estas líneas está
avanzando cuatro unidades por lo que
entonces pensaremos dónde está el 32
está el primer línea fue 4
entonces sumaremos otros 4 esta será 8
12 16 20 24
28 32 y de esta manera sumamos de 4 en 4
hasta llegar al 32 otra manera en la que
podemos pensarlo es por cuánto
multiplicaremos el 4 para llegar al 32
nosotros ya sabemos nuestras tablas de
multiplicar por lo que sabemos que 4 por
8 es igual a 32 así es que contaremos 8
líneas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y de cualquiera
de las dos maneras nos daría 32 como el
resultado correcto veamos comprobemos la
respuesta
es correcto hagamos un par más es estas
me gustan estas son divertidas ahora
tenemos dónde está el 21 en la recta
numérica
en esta línea ahora estamos avanzando
por tres unidades y podemos sumar
entonces 3
9 12 15 18 21 o como sabemos el 3 por 7
es igual a 21 por lo que contaremos 7
líneas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 comprobemos
respuesta y es correcta vamos con una
más donde está el 18 en la recta
numérica tenemos esta recta que empieza
en el 0 y nos desplazamos 3 lugares en
cada uno igual que el ejercicio pasado
así es que tomaremos 3
9 12 15 18 o consultando nuestras tablas
de multiplicar 3 por cuánto nos dará 18
3 por 6 6 18 encontremos seis líneas una
dos tres
456 líneas y estamos completos así es
que revisemos nuestra respuesta y es
correcta una vez más